this is Chicago and this is Chicago's
new inside us everybody settled down bro
I'm gonna need you to pick that out flow
all the way out of headed all the way
down I don't want to see it in the
middle okay according to our records
you're in possession of one of our
microwaves hang on my way and how'd you
make that thing
[Music]
don't let this your phone fool y'all I'm
from here okay I just want to assure you
you're not here to beat anyone today
taste by case we're about to be venture
capitalists outside venture capital
venture capital hallway is bad because
we're taking people's money on an
adventure
whoo cute
I'll be right back I got to get mines
and I gotta go get this dick okay
officer go get that dick me respect the
logo bed I'm sorry ma'am
my brother's a bitch I don't have to
participate in every stupid airship our
tradition that's like thank you hey deep
dish this lasagna across premieres this
July on Comedy Central
god is good so my tongue out will get a
blessing this week